what is up with the blueface collab
album because you guys i don't know man
you guys played me some [ __ ] i just
wanna there's a song where you guys are
dissing each other yeah and you ate them
up yeah for sure you gotta say um no i'm
after that huh you had to say no homo
after that you oh you ate him up
yeah possibly not i don't know what's
going on with this [ __ ]
i don't know because you guys have a
bunch of records yeah man that shit's
supposed to come out and you guys have
great chemistry together yeah that's my
dog
yeah
but i think the last time i saw you guys
you guys were recording and he had
kashan rock with him
do you see their relationship and be
like okay i know now know what not to do
yeah but i also you know i see i know
where they come from they they really
love each other you see them off of the
camera off of the ig yeah they they are
in yeah it's genuine love is just like
you know
they you know they just two fires
together but it's like
it all comes from it all comes from the
heart it all comes from a place of love
yeah so it's like you can't get into
can't get in the way and no [ __ ] like
that
yeah i think if you guys put that on me
you guys had some dope records you play
me yeah man
two people two labels is probably you
know you gotta get all that [ __ ] figured
out yeah it's too much a lot of business
behind this